but we're going to begin with the news
and the news this morning is a
blockbuster settlement in the lawsuit
accusing Fox News of airing lies related
to the 2020 election Fox and Dominion
voting systems avoided a trial agreeing
to one of the largest settlements in any
defamation case in American history the
voting machine company will collect more
than 787 million dollars however Fox
News will not have to make an apology on
its air Scott McFarland was at the
courthouse when the deal was announced
and he joins us now from Wilmington
Delaware where the trial had been set to
take place Scott good morning
Tony this was the ultimate last minute
settlement the jury was seated opening
statements were set to begin when both
sides blinked and agreed to an
eye-popping number
avoiding a trial that would have turned
Fox news's biggest stars into star
Witnesses the company will cut a
787.5 million dollar check to Dominion
voting systems the president's lawyers
alleging a company called Dominion which
Fox is accused of knowingly airing
conspiracy theories and baseless claims
falsely linking Dominion to a scheme to
flip votes during the 2020 election so
much for those claims that voter fraud
never happens of course it happens they
knew it happened that's despite evidence
including internal messages in which Fox
executive Suzanne Scott warned
challenging Trump's bogus claims could
hurt ratings today's settlement
of
787 million five hundred thousand
dollars represents vindication
and accountability lies have
consequences and the settlement included
a public statement from Fox which
Tuesday night said it acknowledged the
Court's rulings finding certain claims
about Dominion to be false but there was
no requirement of an on-air apology or
retraction and fox attorneys declined to
speak to reporters outside the
courthouse the folks at Fox are big boys
and girls and they can say whatever
statement they want in the future to
recognize what they did and what this
court found but we think that the dollar
figure that they agreed to today speaks
for itself the settlement spares
Dominion from having to put its fate in
the hands of 12 jurors and from years of
likely appeals if the case went to trial
they get an acknowledgment that this was
wrong and they get to move on and in
that sense this is more accountability
than people have seen from Fox News
Dominion still has a lawsuit pending
against Newsmax in the same courthouse
in front of this same judge for claims
made after the 2020 election and Fox is
still facing a defamation suit from
voting machine company smartmatic that
suit seeks 2.7 billion dollars and could
yield an even larger some Gail all right
Scott so more to come for Fox News for
sure